I was there watching a nature
documentary
yesterday and if you know this but
spiders don't have spider penises if
they're ever reproducing the like
reproduction organs are in like the
front two arms and that's how they
reproduce which is obviously very
interesting but also really changes
every single spider-man movie right he's
not a hero he's a sex offender like what
he's doing is awful and you're probably
wondering if all my material today is
about animal sexuality yeah I find it
fascinating you know 97% of animal
species have been found to have
homosexual animals like homosexuality
97% of animal species homophobia is
found in one pass yeah they chess know
it says guys were the monsters don't
clap homophobia awful I was in there in
Brazil and the reason I was in Edinburgh
Zoo and I was with the Penguins I was
allowed to go in there and interact with
the Penguins and the zookeeper person I
was with was going around and she was
like and this is where they eat and this
way they sleep and this is where they
swim and these are our two gay penguins
and I went walk she went these are two
gay penguins and I was that one more
time please
she where these are rgk penguins I was
like why did you show me anything else
wasting my time with giraffes tell the
rest of the almost a week off because
this is the zoo now okay and the reason
there are gay penguins is the greatest
reason I've ever heard as an audience
can you tell the difference between a
male and female penguin no neither can
most male penguins and penguins mate for
life
so what happened to one pan gonna be
walking along and he'll drop his keys
there's I don't know but I bend over and
one of the other ones that has been
paying attention I'll just be like dang
and he'll run up and he'll have his way
and then he'll come back up and he'll
start low fiving all of its friends
because penguins kind of high-five yeah
and then the other penguin has to shut
up and turn right it's like it did it
Steve what are you doing the first
babies just like huh well according to
penguin law together favorite now she
tells me this story and I am dying with
laughter right I am happier than I've
ever been I think it's so much better
right it turns out a couple years ago I
and Razoo came to make season right for
the Penguins now the zookeepers know the
straight peg would start having their
sex two gay penguins they started having
their sex alright a couple of weeks
later all the female penguins start to
lay their eggs two gay penguins they
didn't lay an egg and they were confused
by this because they've been doing what
everyone else had been doing let's be
honest probably more
Levin for the weekend and there's
nothing chauffeur and then their
confusion they wandered around their
enclosure until they found a rock that
was slightly egg-shaped
and they just assumed that this was
their egg then that's how it worked so
they put it on their feet the walls the
bags the nest where they then spent the
next couple weeks every hour of every
day taking it in turns sitting on this
rock waiting for it to hatch which is
obviously adorable but only because
they're penguins if your friend turned
up to your house with a stroller and a
boulder shift Karen get off my lawn get
off my lawn this is not acceptable put
the rock back I know it's mine I saw you
pick it up so the zookeepers were
heartbroken because they knew what was
going to happen in a couple of weeks or
the females penguins eggs were gonna
hatch to beautiful baby penguins and the
two gay penguins their rock wasn't gonna
hatch because I'm not explaining that
but fortunately in captivity sometimes
female penguins get a bit excited by all
the penguins are the male penguins there
and sometimes they have too many eggs
so the zookeepers took one of the extra
eggs and they gave it to the gay penguin
parents and if you go to Edinburgh Zoo
for whatever reason you can ask any in
the zoo keepers you can google this
story there's at least one penguin in
Edna's who that has been raised by gay
penguins
is no different from any other penguin
except that it's slightly better dressed